on va parler de ta délinquance en milieu
rural puisque le Sénat examine à partir
d'aujourd'hui la loi l'opmie c'est la
loi sécurité qui prévoit plus de moyens
pour les forces de l'ordre et parmi les
volets du texte la lutte contre la
délinquance en milieu rural c'est le
débat de ce club d'abord Alex on va voir
les chiffres avec vous mais oui rien
alors d'abord on peut dire que la
délinquance et honnêtement plus forte en
milieu
urbain comme milieu rural il faut
rappeler les chiffres sur la période
2015 2019 et bien dans les grandes
villes de plus de 700 000 habitants ont
compté à 10 cambriolages pour 1000
habitants près de quatre faits de
couilles blessures pour la même
proportion de population les chiffres
sont inférieurs dans les villes moyennes
entre 20000 et 50 000 habitants et
encore un niveau en dessous pour les
communes rurales sur cette période et
bien dans les communes rurales on compte
3,8 cambriolages pour 1000 habitants et
deux fois moins de coups et blessures
que dans les métropoles ça c'est pour la
comparaison avec le milieu urbain
ensuite on peut dire qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment une explosion de la délinquance
en milieu rural ces dernières années si
on prend les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur on reste quasiment sûr les
mêmes taux d'infraction le taux de
cambriolage a un peu baissé dans entre
2021 et 2019 légère hausse des coups et
blessures tout comme des faits de
violences sexuelles sur cette période et
on peut dire chaque année que dans les
territoires ruraux il y a une personne
sur 1000 qui se fait voler sa voiture
elle est plutôt contenue cette
délinquance en milieu rural François
bonhomme moi je pense surtout qu'elle
inquiète parce que si on regarde une
photo graphie on peut dire qu'il y a
moins de délits en zone rural si on voit
l'évolution générale on voit quand même
que les zones périphériques puissent se
murbaine puis subir rural puis rural
sont quand même concernés les questions
de cambriolage les questions de violence
aux personnes notamment les violences
intra-familales sont quand même
essentielles et les questions de trafic
de drogue parce qu'aujourd'hui la drogue
n'est plus que dans les agglomérations
ou dans les villes d'importance elle
descend au niveau des villes moyennes et
des petites villes et ça c'est un
phénomène quand même qu'on doit prendre
dont on apprend la mesure et surtout
dont on n'a pas toujours les capacités
de répondre et d'appréhender ce
phénomène on va venir sur les réponses
mais ça veut dire que est-ce qu'il y a
une délinquance spécifique en milieu
oral ou finalement c'est la même celle
qu'on connaît en milieu urbain
spécifique elle porte sur le cambriolage
sur la drogue et sur les 20 centrales
familiales c'est quand même les trois
éléments les plus les plus importants
mais il y a une spécificité dans un
rurale c'est à dire que le fait d'une
faible densité de population me permet
aussi quand même de peut-être mieux
travailler au niveau local pour peu
qu'on se coordonne avec les différents
acteurs locaux pour améliorer le
signalement et pour améliorer aussi la
réponse pénale
beaucoup aussi des retours des maires
heureux c'est sur des incivilités qui
qui sont plutôt sur les dépôts sauvages
sur les vols dans les magasins et avec
la l'augmentation de la précarité ça ça
joue forcément là-dessus et puis sur les
bruits de voisinage donc on n'est pas
forcément sur l'image qu'on a de la
délinquance et quand on regarde parce
que c'est toute la question de la de la
mesure il y a les chiffres du ministère
de l'Intérieur qui qui donne une
indication mais ça dépend du nombre de
dépôts de plainte ça va dépendre aussi
de la libération de la parole sur un
certain nombre le sujet il y a aussi les
enquêtes de victimisation où là c'est
l'Insee qui va voir des des groupes de
population représentatives et qui
demande sur deux ans l'effet délinquance
auxquels ils ont fait face et là on voit
que c'est très stable sur sur 10 ou 15
ans ouais ça veut dire vous dites pour
peu qu'on se coordonne franchement
bonhomme ça veut dire que la
coordination elle est pas toujours là
aujourd'hui si mais elle est surtout le
fait des collectivités locales parce que
évidemment on a des des prescriptions
nous demandant de coordonner avec
différents acteurs locaux ce qu'on fait
naturellement de toute façon alors après
le contacte on met des nouveaux mots
dessus mais naturellement un maire il a
un rapport direct avec un soldes dans le
gendarmerie parce que il a tout intérêt
à échanger des informations qui sont
utiles et puis il y a tout un tas de
j'allais dire d'acteurs locaux qui qui
connaissent finement la population et
qui peuvent vraiment participer à cette
chaîne d'information qui est extrêmement
importante pour signaler et pour faire
émerger et pour signaler ça au fort de
gendarmerie pour intervenir et pour
enquêter simplement ça demande une
chaîne en continuum qui n'est pas
toujours qui n'est pas toujours au
rendez-vous sur cette coordination la
demande c'est un manque de bleu sur le
terrain c'est souvent ça que disent les
mers comme il y a beaucoup moins pour ne
pas dire quasiment pas de police
municipale dans les territoires ruraux
enfin il y a vraiment beaucoup moins et
qu'il y a eu depuis on va dire Nicolas
Sarkozy pas mal de suppression de postes
même si il y en a eu des nouveaux depuis
enfin des nouvelles embauches depuis
c'est ce manque de de couverture et de
gendarmes et derrière les élus aussi ce
qui ce qui remarque c'est que à en le
faisant par le nombre d'habitants il y a
des fois des territoires très grands qui
n'ont pas beaucoup de gendarmes parce
qu'il y a pas beaucoup d'habitants mais
il faut couvrir des zones très grandes
et c'est là où ça manque de de gendarmes
sur le terrain et donc parfois d'une
certaine proximité et une visibilité
aussi de ces forces de l'ordre ouais
justement puisque vous parlez de ça on
va voir peut-être l'une des solutions on
va aller dans le Calvados c'est Jérôme
Rabier qui nous y emmène et depuis
juillet une gendarmerie
le département chaque jour elle
s'installe dans une commune différente
comme au mollet literie où on se rend où
chaque jeudi les habitants peuvent
échanger et effectuer leur démarche
comme par exemple porter plainte on
regarde
comme tous les jeudis matins ces jours
de marché au mollets litry 3000
habitants et depuis 3 mois au côté des
vendeurs traditionnels un autre stand un
peu particulier s'est installé au pied
de la mairie un camping-car au couleur
de la gendarmerie nationale alors là
nous avons les nos locaux la brigade
mobile de proximité avec le camping car
qui a été aménagé avec les rondages de
la gendarmerie et où nous avons
également deux VTT électrique qui nous
servent pour des patrouilles en VTT dans
les hameaux isolés tout autour de la
commune ici les habitants peuvent venir
demander des renseignements être
accompagnés dans leur démarche et même
déposer plainte comme dans une vraie
gendarmerie le camping-car
issu d'une saisie judiciaire est fait
pour cela et là je vais vous faire
entrer dans les dans nos locaux donc
vous avez ici
un poste de travail qui permet d'être en
liaison avec tous les fichiers nationaux
donc qui permet de questionner et
également de prendre un numéro de
procès-verbal pour enregistrer les
plaintes donc la personne s'installe ici
on a un écran dévié qui permet d'avoir
une lecture de la procédure en direct
chaque jour de la semaine le camping-car
s'installa si dans une commune du
département une proximité retrouvée pour
les habitants qui auparavant devait
faire 30 km pour accéder à une
gendarmerie moi je trouve que c'est
super et j'avais remarqué ça depuis un
petit moment vous étiez ici j'y un jour
quand je vais avoir un petit peu de
temps sur mon travail avoir du travail
il faut que j'aille les voir pour mais
je trouve ça super ce qui est important
d'avoir pérennisé à cet endroit là
d'ailleurs parce que la population ça
rassure aussi les gens de voir un petit
peu plus les gendarmes justement dans
les communes
c'est bon je trouve ça c'est bien c'est
pas mal expérimenté depuis trois mois le
dispositif doit être pérennisé mais du
côté de la gendarmerie le satisfait site
est déjà général on va au devant de la
population et des maires à s'inscrit
dans la police de la sécurité du
quotidien bien évidemment et c'est bien
apprécié des gens donc maintenant c'est
bien identifié et on commence à avoir
beaucoup de visites voir des prises de
plainte sur ce dispositif mobile un
dispositif qui est complété par des
patrouilles à vélo mais aussi à pied
dans les allées du marché un petit
prospectus de d'opération tranquillité
seniors je vous ai identifié comme
senior vous m'en voulez pas
l'occasion aussi de renouer le lien avec
habitants et commerce si vous avez
besoin vous n'hésitez pas vous venez
nous voir bonne journée à vous au revoir
placez juste devant la mairie le
camping-car est aussi un lieu privilégié
pour échanger avec le maire de la
commune qui espère une vraie gendarmerie
dans l'avenir mais se réjouit de cette
présence hebdomadaire un bon nombre de
personnes aurait été un peu frileuse
entre guillemets de venir déposer
les gens aller vers vers vous et là
c'est beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
simple
effectivement c'est pas le vrai service
public mais en tant que mère je vais
vous dire ce qui compte moi c'est le
résultat si c'est vraiment le moyen pour
revenir à quelque chose de cohérent et
alors c'est bien je prends ce qui compte
c'est que ce camping-car porte ses
fruits ce qui compte c'est que la
population est très satisfaite alors
vrai service ou faux service public je
ne sais pas mais en attendant résultat
très positifs 25 départements pilote
avait été choisi pour expérimenter ce
nouveau type de présence de la
gendarmerie la loi d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur prévoit que 200 brigades de
gendarmerie en milieu rural et
périurbain soient créés sans forcément
copier le dispositif original et mobile
du Calvados
de remettre des gendarmes sur le terrain
est-ce que ce dispositif c'est un bon
moyen
ça participe à plusieurs éléments
nécessaires d'abord une visibilité et je
pense que ça c'est vraiment important
que les gens ont le sentiment qu'il y a
une présence pour les gendarmerie en
espèces à proximité ensuite une
immersion c'est à dire que les gendarmes
connaissent leur population circulent ne
soient pas cloisonnés ça c'est
extrêmement important et puis un élément
qu'on n'a pas vu dans certaines communes
de plus en plus c'est quand même la
vidéoprotection le développement des
nouvelles technologies a quand même
permis depuis une dizaine quinzaine
d'années de s'équiper en vidéoprotection
je rappelle combien ça peut être
important pour à la fois pour les
enquêtes à la fois comme moyen de preuve
dans un cas de pénale et dans la
procédure pénale et ça je rappelle qu'il
y a 15 ans c'était vraiment un frein
c'était même c'était même dénoncer comme
une atteinte liberticide aujourd'hui
franchement on reviendra jamais en
arrière parce que ça permet vraiment
d'améliorer la chaîne pénale d'améliorer
le taux de lucidation et les
technologique même si c'est pas un totem
c'est vraiment un élément important du
dispositif sécurité et là sur ce roman
sur ce camping-car qui sillonne dans le
département on l'a vu c'est un jour une
commune est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut parfois que les gendarmerie se
rapproche des habitants parce que les
habitants ils sont pas toujours à même
d'aller vers un gendarme ou un policier
oui et puis on voit ça va dépendre des
des
sujets quand c'est un cambriolage on va
quand même assez facilement chez les
gendarmes porter plainte quand on parle
de violences intrafamiliales de
violences faites aux femmes c'est la
libération de la parole dans les
territoires oraux est beaucoup plus
compliqué et le fait de se rapprocher
des gendarmes et un travail plus
compliqué et donc le fait de
l'identifier de savoir que il est sur la
place la place de la du village tel jour
et cueillait ce rapport à la population
peut permettre de de rapprocher les
gendarmes et et d'augmenter les les
déclarations des délits
là dessus est-ce que le maillage
gendarme il est suffisant en milieu
rural où est-ce qu'il existe des déserts
sécuritaires comme il existe des déserts
médicaux
le maillage il pourrait être sans doute
améliorer c'est sûr mais c'est aussi un
terme d'efficacité qu'il faut voir vous
savez je parlais de présence de présence
gendarmerie parfois des habitants
viennent vous signaler des des points de
Deal ou des points d'échange de drogue
et il faut savoir qu'une enquête
gendarmerie ça peut prendre 6 mois pour
démenteler un réseau donc il y a
toujours une latence et qui pas toujours
comprises alors même que les gendarmes
sont peut-être en train de de faire des
des surveillances et d'améliorer
l'enquête donc il y a double aspect il y
a le long terme qui demande du temps et
de l'énergie et de de l'investissement
des forces sécurité et puis à la
présence et on peut pas opposer les deux
les deux sont nécessaires après il y a
notre souci qui est un peu sous-jacent à
la Loki c'est le continent de justice
sécurité
parce que on peut améliorer ouvrir des
brigades je rappelle qu'il y en a quand
même 300 donc il faut relativiser le
chiffre mais si on a le fonctionnement
justice est un stylé on a quand même de
grosses difficultés pour arriver une
fois l'élucidation atteinte à une
condamnation une condamnation exécutée
justement parce que parler de cette loi
évidemment il y a un volet de lutte
contre la délinquance rurale Alex que
contient précisément cette loi là-dessus
alors déjà la promesse de campagne
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de doubler la
présence des policiers et des gendarmes
sur le terrain et donc la mesure phare
de cette loi d'opmie c'est donc la
création de 200 brigades de gendarmerie
en milieu rural dont certaines pourront
être mobiles actuellement la gendarmerie
compte 3500 brigades qui ont la charge
de 95% du territoire national et ses 15
dernières c'est 15 dernières années et
bien 500 brigades de gendarmerie ont été
supprimés notamment sous Nicolas Sarkozy
pour faire des économies et l'objectif
du gouvernement actuel c'est de recréer
deux à trois brigades de gendarmerie par
département en se concentrant sur les
secteurs qui ont gagné en population et
puis aussi ceux qui sont désertés en
service public alors là pour l'instant
le gouvernement a lancé une phase de
concertation avec les collectivités
locales pour voir dans quel territoire
implanter ces brigades cette
concertation ce sera jusqu'à début
janvier et ensuite les premières
brigades seront implantées et seront
prêtes pour l'été prochain parmi les
autres mesures qui peuvent et bien aider
à mieux lutter contre cette délinquance
rurale on peut compter les moyens
supplémentaires pour la gendarmerie
notamment pour enquêter avec la création
de plus de 3000 postes d'assistants en
quête pour assurer notamment les tâches
administratives des enquêtes de
gendarmerie la possibilité pour tous les
gendarmes de se former et de devenir
officier de police judiciaire et puis ce
texte finance la rénovation des casernes
et donc l'amélioration des conditions de
travail et d'accueil des victimes enfin
on finit par préciser que
l'administration du ministère de
l'Intérieur va également être en partie
délocalisée transféré dans les
territoires avec
qui seront redirigées de Paris vers 16
villes de provinces donc la
déconcentration de l'État c'est aussi
dans le domaine de la sécurité
[Musique]
François bonhomme pour vous c'est une
bonne loi est-ce que vous voterez c'est
ce texte en tout cas on va la demander
et il y a quand même une sorte de choses
qui ne dispose pas par exemple les
Rhodes urbain qui est un nouveau
phénomène qui a qui a beaucoup augmenté
on va proposer notre groupe de renforcer
la peine pour ce type de délit qui est
une véritable fléau et qui parfois même
célébrée par le cinéma un film qui sort
financé sur fonds publics qui est quand
même une forme de célébration de rando
urbain comme c'était une mode or les
rôles urbain c'est vraiment un délit qui
à la fois
fortement à l'ordre public les gens sont
importunés dans leur vie ils peuvent
plus dormir et en même temps ils sont
menacés et puis ça ça met en danger les
personnes non seulement qui se livrent à
ce genre de pratique mais évidemment il
y a eu des accidents dernièrement qui
ont défrayé la chronique avec des
enfants qui ont été grave blessé suite à
cela donc c'est tout un ensemble de
choses et je vais on va pas se laisser
impressionner par les chiffres avancés
dans ce projet de loi parce que
pas la hauteur on affiche des créations
bon on n'est pas défavor le création par
principe mais ce qu'on veut nous c'est
des résultats et les résultats on voit
bien que on peut mettre tous les moyens
qu'on veut si on n'a pas ce continent
avec la justice qui a qui qui a de
graves difficultés en manque de
magistrats encore un manque de greffier
encore on a des des délais de jugement
qui sont très longs on a des difficultés
d'exécution de peine c'est quand même un
grave problème donc on peut mobiliser
des moyens mais c'est même pire quand on
mobilise de Fort moyen et qu'on n'arrive
pas aux résultats à une bonne
administration d'injustice
et puis il y a une grande oubliée dans
la loi il y a rien pour l'instant sur
les collectivités alors qu'elles ont
quand même des problématiques de
recrutement des policiers municipaux où
on voit qu'il y a une guerre de
recrutement entre territoire et puis
aussi la question de la coordination
avec les gendarmes et la police
nationale qui était dans la loi sécurité
globale qui avait été censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel et depuis c'est
pas revenu dans le texte et ici les élus
locaux en tout cas s'inquiètent de ne
pas apparaître dans cette dans cet état
de loi la police municipale c'est un peu
la grande oubliée de ce texte pour vous
franchement bien sûr tous les maires
savent que combien la police municipale
peut vraiment apporter un élément
supplémentaire dans sur un territoire
pour peu généralement le cas qu'elle se
Cordonne à des fois gendarmerie mais il
y a une vraie frilosité là-dessus le
texte ne reconnaît absolument pas le
rôle des policiers municipaux alors même
qui sont devenus essentiels c'est eux
qui coordonnent par exemple la B2
surveillance la vidéoprotection c'est il
travaille généralement un bon
intelligence parce que tout le monde
ayant intérêt mais bizarrement avec la
gendarmerie ou c'est un rôle spécifique
mais bizarrement c'est ce texte parle
autant parce qu'il par ce qui ne pas que
par ce qui figure la police municipale
ne figure pas les questions de
technologie on en parle mais
l'intelligence artificielle ou même ou
même la reconnaissance faciale c'est un
vrai c'est un vrai domaine qui le
ministre de l'Intérieur refuse
d'intégrer la reconnaissance faciale
comme on a refusé il y a 15 ans la
vidéoprotection mais la technologie
évolue on est surtout au Sénat
protecteur de liberté donc je pense
qu'on a les capacités de border et de
mettre des garde-fous mais en se refuse
à ce type de débat alors même que c'est
vraiment devenu un élément essentiel et
qui de toute façon le facteur humain est
irremplaçable mais que cette technologie
nouvelle Vienne en complément de la
présence humaine ça c'est quelque chose
que j'ai du mal à comprendre et qui ne
figure pas dans le texte
après sur les territoires ruraux il y a
quand même beaucoup plus de demandes de
d'hommes sur le terrain ou de femmes sur
le terrain que
l'enjeu technologique qu'il a va quand
même être plus pour des territoires plus
urbains à part la la protection
évidemment mais on va être un peu plus
éloigné dans les retours de terrain et
les et les mers qui qui nous parlent
là-dessus ce qu'ils veulent c'est de
retour de gendarmes sur le terrain et de
force pour être au plus près de la
population et faire remonter les
problèmes puisque on parlait de des
collectivités des élus en milieu rural
peut-être encore plus qu'en milieu
urbain l'élu local il est à portée de
baffe à portée d'engueulade comme dirait
Gérard Larcher dans ce texte les
républicains les sénateurs les
républicains souhaitent aussi durcir les
peines contre ceux qui s'en prennent qui
font des violences envers les élus
évidemment Homer comme d'autres sont des
délégataires de l'autorité publique et
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui combien
l'autorité par nature et défiée un maire
est en première ligne constamment et il
a d'autant plus je veux dire son
attachement à la présence de gendarmes
que que c'est presque les seuls qui sont
en première ligne avec les gendarmes
voilà il y a il y a un siècle qui avait
le curé qui jouait un peu le rôle
d'amortisseur social c'est plus le cas
malheureusement c'est comme ça et donc
le maire souvent se trouve démuni parce
que c'est vraiment celui qui qui absorbe
toutes les craintes les désarroi et
parfois l'agressivité de des administrer
parce que il y a des comportements tout
à fait inciviques et cela ils doivent
donner lieu à des réactions immédiates
et et
du procureur de la République alors ça
c'est un peu amélioré mais on a beaucoup
encore d'agressions d'agression physique
agression verbale et là aussi on a
sous-évalué ce phénomène parce que
combien de mères se font agresser
verbalement ne déposent pas plainte par
exemple
agression agression physique en général
c'est enregistré et il y a une réaction
pas toujours une condamnation à la
hauteur de ce qu'on pourrait espérer
mais il y a un vrai phénomène de cet
ordre là sûrement parce qu'il y avait
déjà eu une loi après la mort du maire
de cygne à l'engagement et proximité
justement pour aider les élus locaux et
aujourd'hui il faut faire plus encore on
voit dans les chiffres en tout cas que
entre 2021 et 2020 il y a une forte
augmentation alors on peut l'expliquer
par le contexte sanitaire aussi qui a
tendu la situation les débats sur le
Pass par exemple mais il y a il y a une
vraie inquiétude sur le terrain et
principalement dans les petites communes
de tension et si on regarde les derniers
chiffres on parlait quand même de 605
mères adjoints de mer ou d'adjoint qui
ont
enfin qui ont eu des violences physiques
en 2021 donc c'est quand même pas
négligeable même si on a 34000 et
quelques communes c'est quand même pas
plus de 600 élus c'est quand même pas
négligeable et on suivra bien sûr un
examen de cette loi ça commence cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous en parler vous
restez
[Musique]